bonjour à tous un oxymore n'est pas une
notion mathématique et pourtant
j'aimerais vous parler des mathématiques
comme logique de l'irrationnel humains
mathématicienne de formation j'ai appris
la rationalité aujourd'hui je gère un
campus universitaire mon quotidien et
d'irrationnel humain je viens en tunisie
pays des oxymores la question que je me
suis posée et faut-il être rationnel
pour réussir pour moi la rationalité
mathématiques doit être une logique de
pensée et non pas de fonctionnement je
vais vous raconter une petite anecdote
après un bac à tunis je suis parti à
paris pour faire une prépa les études
étaient difficiles et l'éloignement du
cocon familial n'a pas arrangé les
choses pour les petits bobos de parcours
j'avais l'habitude d'appeler ma mère
structure et rationnels comme et des
ailes mettaient souvent à m'en sortir
mais au bout du énième ratage j'ai
appelé mon père désespéré
c'était peut-être le moment de d'arrêter
ses études et de rentrer en tunisie et
je l'aï dit j'ai complètement raté le
devoir de maths
c'était vraiment du chinois pour moi
alors il me répondit pas grave ma fille
approche chinois
cette petite réaction inattendue m'a
procuré un moment de bonheur immédiat
ça m'a fait énormément de bien
il ne pas apporter une solution à mon
problème et pourtant il m'a fait sourire
je pense que jusqu'à ce jour il veille
réalise toujours pas l'effet de cette
petite boutade pendant un moment de
désespoir
j'étais fier quelques années plus tard
quand je peux lui dire je n'ai toujours
pas appris le chinois mais je suis
docteur en met
j'aimerais partager avec vous deux
enseignements que j'ai tiré de cette
petite histoire qui ont façonné mon
caractère et changer ma façon de voir
des choses la première face à une
situation complexe
pas la peine d'alourdir encore
l'ambiance autant en rire
la deuxième pour réussir il n'y a pas
qu'un seul chemin est le meilleur chemin
c'est probablement à soin de le créer
aujourd'hui je gère le campus tunisien
de l'université paris dauphine
celle là même qui m'a formé je développe
des programmes orientés vers les métiers
d'avenir et les métiers à forte valeur
ajoutée en tunisie et plus généralement
en afrique
j'utilise les mathématiques différemment
et cela me convient parfaitement
j'ai changé mon quotidien de la gestion
de la rationalité mathématiques à la
gestion de l'irrationnel de l'humain
contrairement à une démonstration de
maths où tout se construit sur des
étapes toutes justifiées et vérifier les
unes après les autres
le capital humain se construit sur
l'incertain et l'erreur on peut faire
des erreurs pour pouvoir avancer
le tout est de savoir en tirer les
enseignements se relever vite et bien
le développement du capital humain
qu'ils soient des étudiants des
entrepreneurs ou des collaborateurs en
entreprise
suit un processus aléatoires qui évolue
dans le temps ils dépendent de deux
variables l'optimisme et la ténacité
mais vous allez me dire que cela dépend
énormément du travail pour moi le
travail est une variable engendré et non
pas une variable explicative
si nous avons l'optimisme et la ténacité
nécessaire alors le travail suivra le
développement du capital humain n'est
pas un processus continu c'est un
processus à sauver car il rebondit à
chaque fois on a une période de
complexité qu'on peut appeler aussi en
mathématiques un temps d'arrêt pour les
noms matin c'est quoi un temps d'arrêt
un temps d'arrêt est un moment aléatoire
que l'on ne peut reconnaître que lorsque
la catastrophe arrive
concrètement pour un étudiant ça peut
être ce moment où il reçoit des
résultats en dessous de ses attentes
alors qu'il a bien travaillé pendant
toute l'année pour un entrepreneur
cela peut être le moment où sa
créativité bloqués à cause d'un manque
de financement suit un pitch et pour un
pays comme la tunisie
cela peut être un 14 janvier 2000 ans
date à laquelle un président quitte son
pays suite au soulèvement de la
population
bref pendant ce temps d'arrêt on est
désorienté et pourtant il faut faire un
choix
ce choix est une option stratégique car
c'est ça qui va permettre à la courbe
d'avoir un saut vers le bas ou vers le
vers le haut plutôt ou vers le bas
c'est bien sûr une option byword car la
décision qu'on va prendre
dépend énormément des expériences succès
et chaque passé alors la plupart des
gens pensent que l'option qui mène vers
le succès et aboutit au bonheur est la
suivante il faut travailler dur et si on
travaille dur
alors on réussit mieux et si on réussit
mieux alors on est heureux ça ne se
passe pas du tout comme ça
les spécialistes des sciences du bonheur
suggère de faire exactement le contraire
en temps d'arrêt il faut d'abord
commencer par tenter d'engendrer un
sentiment de bonheur en élevant sans
seuil de positivité cette sensation de
bonheur va permettre au cerveau en mode
positif de mieux visualiser la réussite
est de s'y projeter et si on visualise
mieux la réussite
alors on est plus motivé et plus
efficace le tout est de savoir comment
engendré cette sensation de bonheur
comment sourire quand la situation
comparée compliqué ou insurmontable il
s'agit pas de se mentir ou de traduire
des éléments négatifs en éléments
positifs mais d'essayer de trouver les
points positifs qui nous font changer
notre perception de la situation selon
ces spécialistes des sciences delà des
bonnes du bonheur seulement 25% des
réussites professionnelles sont liées au
qi 75% des réussites professionnelles
sont liées au niveau de l'optimisme
l'environnement relationnel et la
capacité de transformer sans stress on
un défi et non pas une menace
je me souviens encore de cette période
juste après le 14 janvier 2000 ans ayant
été victime d'un pillage la nuit du 14
au 15
mon sentiment prédominant et elle a peur
avec des amis nous avons tenté de
trouver ces moments de bonheur que seule
la révolution nous permettait d'avoir
nous avons contacté jr lauréate est de
1000 ans jr est l'auteur de du projet
face to face entre palestine israël nous
avons photographié et coller une
mosaïque de photos de tunisiens partout
en tunisie en remplacement de la photo
du président déchu jr a baptisé ce
projet artocratie le plus drôle de 7
cette histoire était de me retrouver en
train de coller des photos sur la porte
de france à trois heures du matin avec
les copains pour éviter pour éviter la
foule - collé des photos à 3 heures du
matin il n'était même pas venu à
l'esprit de le faire quand la sécurité
était bien établie
certes ces moments de bonheur n'ont
aucun impact sur la situation économique
et sociale du pays
mais cela nous a procuré un moment de
bonheur et le fait de participer avec jr
dans son art nous a permis de changer
notre perception de la situation
j'ai en a fait un livre est une des
photos a fait la couverture
dagg it finalement ce temps d'arrêt
national était l'occasion d'une
explosion artistique
nous sommes passés de 23 ans de
dictature et de pensée unique
un débordement de liberté d'expression
on a découvert des rappeurs ndagane en
même temps que des niqab et et des
barbus on s'est même retrouvé avec une
semaine tunisienne en même temps que des
prédicateurs moyenâgeux invité dans nos
mosquées tous tunisiens et ont eu la
même éducation et la même histoire
alors si certains voient en mon pays
cette complexité d'être à la fois arabes
musulmans et démocrates
moi je vois cet excès oxymore qui est en
train de tracer son propre chemin vers
un avenir plus prospère
les jeunes démocraties se construisent
avec des temps d'arrêt et que avec des
temps d'arrêt et le réussit dépendent de
la réussite de ces jeunes et c'est
particulièrement ces jeunes qui vend ces
temps d'arrêt une opportunité de
s'exprimer de participer de construire
qui pourront nous garantir le succès et
l'espoir de demain alors en étant femme
tunisienne mathématicienne et directrice
d'un campus je suis convaincu que mon
rôle est d'accompagner ces jeunes dans
leur propre trajectoire
afin qu'il réussisse antec en tant
qu'étudiant mais mieux encore en tant
que citoyen merci beaucoup